in other news the Trump administration
is extending an invite to Russian
President Vladimir Putin to visit the
u.s. early next year but after what many
saw as disastrous a disastrous summit
between Putin and Trump President Trump
in July and intelligence agencies
confidence that Russia did meddle in the
2016 elections some in both parties are
now wondering aloud if that invite is a
good idea
State Department correspondent rich
Edson has our story
Russian President Vladimir Putin may
soon return to the White House we have
invited President Putin to Washington
after the first of the year for
basically a full day of consultations
traveling in the former Soviet state of
Georgia national security adviser John
Bolton says officials are still
discussing the schedule Russian state
media say Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
and Russian Foreign Minister Sergei
Lavrov spoke today to prepare for
meetings between the two presidents if
President Putin accepts the invitation
it would be his first trip to the White
House since September 2005 presidents
Trump and Putin last met at a July
summit in Helsinki with a press
conference where President Trump
discussed Russia's interference in the
2016 US election
I have President Putin he just said it's
not Russia I will say this I don't see
any reason why it would be that brought
widespread criticism even amongst senior
congressional Republicans everyone who's
dealt with Putin understands fully that
the best way to deal with him is through
strength and I just felt like the
president's comments made us look as a
nation more like a pushover Bolton also
said the administration wants to
maintain discussions with the Russian
government on strategic stability
disarmament and regional conflicts first
the president may briefly meet again
with Putin next month in Paris while the
two are there for the commemoration of
the end of the first world war
Brett Richards in at the State
Department rich thank you